[Musk] turned his focus to Apple,
claiming
the company was going to withhold
from its Apple store
and asking
if Apple hated free speech in Am
and tweeting at Apple
CEO Tim Cook asking,
what is going on here?
Then later in the day, MS.
t's that he will publish
what he calls the Twitter files,
the public deserves
to know
what Twitter has done in the pas
regarding free speech suppressio
and then finally,
I'm sure
there's going to be more, though
He posted and penned a tweet
saying that this is the battle
for the future of civilization.
If free speech is lost, even in
tyranny is all that lies ahead.
So glad we have our colleague
and friend Donie O'Sullivan
here with us to talk about all I
Where do you begin?
I mean, right.
It's like you
have to laugh because it's like,
what else do you do know?
CEO operates like this,
but it's really scary
is is it not to see
some of this stuff
from the Gone With what is.
Yeah.
A lot.
A lot going on.
Let's start with Apple
because that's
what's really important here.
The Apple App Store
has a kind of quality control,
so you can't just get any app
on your phone.
Apple,
that's the app's
one to make sure
there's not viruses in it
that could be spying on us,
but also to make sure
that they don't
have apps on their app store
that promotes hate speech or,
you know, dangerous misinformati
We saw
Parler, which was a right
wing social media network
getting kicked off the App Store
for a while last year
until they cleaned up their hate
speech rules.
And I think Twitter.
Elon Musk is concerned
because he has
taken down all the guardrails
when it comes to the rules
on the platform
that Apple might turn around
and say, hey,
we don't want you on our app
store anymore.
And if that happens and Twitter
was essentially unavailable
as an app put in iPhones,
that could be devastating for Tw
One other important point
when it comes to Apple,
we learned yesterday
that Apple has basically stopped
advertising on Twitter.
And The Washington Post reported
that Apple in quarter
one in the first quarter of this
was actually Twitter's
biggest advertiser,
spending a $48 million
in the first quarter alone.
So you can also see another reas
why Musk is taking issue with Ap
Well, that's
that's the that's the thing here
Whether he's doing it
this is some out of some despera
if he's doing it for
attention to try
to get more eyes on Twitter.
But the real issue, Donny,
is that Apple is not the only on
major advertisers are no longer
advertising on Twitter.
And that poses a huge problem
beyond just Elon Musk
for the for the company,
the stability
and the longevity of the company
Absolutely.
And look,
and speaking of kind of tearing
the whole rulebook that Twitter
had these past few years,
we just learned overnight
this and I want to show you
this screenshot
from from Twitter, his website.
They are no longer enforcing the
19 misinformation policy.
Since 2020 Twitter has been work
they were definitely not always
perfect
and there was a lot of misinform
about COVID.
About the vaccines on the platfo
but there was a rules in place
and policies in place.
We learned that that is no more
that is no longer happening at T
and that again
might be another reason
why Apple might say, hey,
we don't want you to have us.
We don't want to have you
on our app store.
Finally, under that policy,
according to Twitter's own numbe
since 2020 Twitter suspended
11,000 accounts
for sharing COVID misinformation
It's very possible
that a lot of those accounts
we're going to see coming back
onto the platform.
And one final thing, guys.
The reason why I'm here in Flori
and working on my time
is that we're about to hear toda
a Twitter employee,
Yoel Ross,
who was
in charge
of writing a lot of these rules.
He left the company a few weeks
He basically couldn't
work under Elon Musk anymore.
And he's about to speak out
at a conference
here in Florida a little later t